I've chased the one pursuing me. She's trying to add me. She's
trying to add my girlfriend. She's trying to add other people.
She's hopping on people's I don't think we did after this one
or whatever, but like every strategy that I've ignoring her didn't
work. Being friends with her kind of worked a little bit. Wait.
>> They have these talking points against you. Do you think
I like that? I was making things up. You can hear what I was
I was a huge fan of yours, okay? It's disappointing. It's like
disappointing You don't think that would >> Dude, NO, NO,
STOP, STOP, STOP, DUDE. YOU CAN'T KEEP doing this. You don't
think You don't think You don't think You don't think What she's
She is constantly bringing me up.
>> And I'll watch I'll watch a little bit of Aiden with
the laugh portion and then we're going to We'll see what else
we do >> But it is the dedicated,
constant
focus on me, intense focus on me. I literally cannot breathe
without somebody finding an issue, without find somebody finding
and then it's just extended over years of time. >> hearing
I Okay, who is doing Who Who is doing this? What Is she serious?
>> Any of these people like they did I admit that people
would talk about you and make fun of you. It literally I remember
explicitly it died down for a long time and then it was after
you like start going on stream and making comments like 50% of
men have probably like shared like images of women without their
consent that all of a sudden everybody was interested in talking
about you again. >> What What did I What did I say 50%?
Did I say I don't care about people talking about me.
Okay. I I don't care about >> She also said every snarker
has done it, which was just a weird comment to make. >> ask
on that. Why do you think they went after Stratus for that? >> Because
that's like an absurd comment to make. I think it's minimizing
>> No, no, no, wait. I >> She also She just said
every snarker did it. So, she was trying to pick a fight,
Is that not Is that not literally the quote that every one of
these snarkers has done this? Most men do this. Every one of
these snarkers has done this. I could have sworn that was the
quote. >> hard about what I'm going to say. Why would they
go after Stratus for that? >> Cuz you believe that it was
that she aligned herself with you. So, then >> Exactly.
Hold on, wait a second, Stratus. Did we talk at all in like the
past like two
>> Why would you have to talk? You don't have to talk.
You can easily perceive that even though Aiden and I don't talk,
we have roughly the same beliefs on things. Why would you have
to talk to
Why would you have to talk to Stardust to be aligned on something?
That's all. >> I have a bird to take care of. I will see
you guys later. Thank you. >> calling in and I hope your
bird gets better in all seriousness. Thank you. >> Thank
you. What I was going to say was that I think it's funny coming
from Stardust because Stardust like like actually emboldened
sick when he was making the documentary about me and was actually
A-logging me and lying about me online. And I was also going
to say like Steven, you built this community based off of harassment
and A-logging people and now you're like, why is it happening
to me? Like you built this brick by brick. This is the community
that you built for yourself and others. Like this is this helps
you when you're against And then when and then when they're and
then when people if I could finish and then when people are against
you
>> Hassan, Lav
I guess kind of me, but mostly Hassan Hassan and some associated
people.
>> Lav, you do have to answer this >> No, we don't.
I need to finish my point before I answer his questions and I'll
take questions when she's done.
He's scared of me. He's scared of saying this. Like he's he's
literally he's scared of me like he he is doing this as like
a like a baby childhood. Anyway, I'll continue because I know
that at least people are going to remind him of what I'm saying.
He's like, why are people harassing my child? And then he'll
literally like stream with his child, his minor child like on
his streams. Like you're putting him on the internet. You are
a content creator. Not only that, you're a content creator that
engages in blood sports. You're a content creator who harasses
other people. Of course it's not justified. I would never say
it was justified.
You're not allowing me to finish. >> Hold on. One point
at a time. >> Yeah, but one point at a >> Again,
again, just like literally describing some lack of concern.
Literally describing some lack of concern on Destiny's part and
Whit goes, "That doesn't mean it's justified."
Yeah, we all know that.
I What Why did you think she was justifying it or saying it was
okay? Like one point at a time. It's It's like only these people
who suddenly lost their ability to understand the difference
between describing reality and prescribing >> I I don't
need to do that. I can lay out all the things I'm thinking and
then I can take questions. >> Well, they're going to >> wait
5 seconds after I finish. It's not like I'm trying to silence
you. You can wait. Thank you. And not only that, what's ridiculous
is that when I was going through all of this and I said everyone,
"Hey, like something's happening to me." And everyone was just
like, "Um, I think you're mentally ill. You might just not be,
you know, well enough to be online." Guess what? I got offline
and it disappeared. Stardust, do you realize that you can just
turn your laptop off? Steven, do you realize you can literally
just close your application? Do you realize that you're a 6,000
viewer and you're like a seven you from anywhere from 6,000 to
12,000 viewers.
The people with 20 viewers and literally like cortisol spiking
because of it. It's insane. Grow up. >> They're trying
to make you look crazy. You're correct. Don't let them make you
look [laughter] crazy. Don't let them make you look crazy. >> Stop.
Destiny. Go ahead. >> Destiny is just Anavar at this point.
Like Like he just spirals on any mention of himself and he can't
stop responding to it. Like he's just Anavar.
He Anavar without the treatment or anything, right? Anavar learned
to control it. Destiny is just unironically
>> Can you stop treating people like children? I know that
for you women aren't real people whatever. >> everyone
to treat you like a child right now. Stop bullying me online.
Stop bullying me online. Then log off. Log off, Steven. You don't
have to see it. Log off. You make enough money. You're successful
enough to where you don't have to pay attention to it.
>> You're so scared.
>> They They literally couldn't respond
and they moved her out. Oh, well, cool. >> the record,
my community didn't hate log Anna. That's crazy. I'll talk about
Yes, they did. What what the [__] is this guy saying?
What do you mean your community didn't A log Anna? Are you Is
this a dude?
Who do you think built Anna Forrest Kiwi Farms thread? The only
reason she had a KF thread was because of her interactions with
Destiny. The only reason she had any streaming audience was because
of her interactions with Destiny. What are we talking about,
man? This is This is just an insane thing to say. He just tries
to use set reality but not engage with it. It's weird.
You literally people would still bring her up and watch the stream.
I don't know. What is Destiny saying?
I literally was around around this time.
I know that people would watch it cuz I watched some of that
content from his from his chat. Everybody was watching it, talking
about it. What is he talking about? Like anybody who was in that
chat just knows this is a lie. Every single person knows this
is an obvious lie that this was Every single time she went live,
every DJR that was active or like in that chat at the time would
tune in.
What We're just lying about it now, I guess. She was like screaming
and crying and responding to comments. People on Kiwi Farms started
posting about it. Zerka started to farm the ever living [__]
out of her. That crazy That crazy clip where she's like, "Why
did you call me princess?" That was on a Zerka stream. But she
The only reason I joined that call was because she was already
talking about me. She hasn't been for months. Yeah, just just
to confirm what Destiny is saying here. One of the the issues
that I had because I had just started streaming at the time,
I had just gotten introduced to the space and the incentives
to bring on Anna and basically get her to break down in order
for everyone to cover it after was very very high. We as a community
decided to not do that because we thought it would be taking
advantage of someone who's going through a thing, but the idea
that it was Destiny's community that was egging this on >> Well,
no, the claim I'm pretty sure the claim was that I'm pretty sure
the claim was that they were A-logging her and it sounds like
that's not even being It sounds like the dispute is that they
just have a reason to do it. I'm pretty sure SHE WAS SCREAMING.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY.
DESTINY'S not arguing they didn't follow her. He didn't follow
her around. There's nothing like that. It was just that it was
justified. He's allowed to do it. When Destiny does something
that's unethical for anybody else, it's okay because he's defending
himself, obviously. >> We were not A-logging her. She was
stalking me. You don't Hold on. Anna was stalking me. Do you
understand that? >> Okay, um I >> No, no, no, wait,
no, no, wait. Do you understand? When she was going live, every
single day to talk about me in my community, Anna was stalking
me. >> Uh I don't know if it's like stalking and talking
about it. She could have been. I'd have to look at it, but I
don't I haven't seen proof she was stalking you. >> If
you go live to talk about a person every single day to cry and
scream about them, we don't want anything to do with you. You
wouldn't consider that to be >> If you If they have been
significantly wronged by you, I think they would just be like
an emotional like this is what I'm doing. I think stalking I
think I think well >> Aiden's like uh Destiny's cordy spiking.
Aiden has no cordy spike right now. Aiden's just very
>> Shorts. Yes, I agree. That's why if we introduce like
the usage of certain tactics, people can provide infinite
>> Dude, that actually would be so funny if Aiden brings
up Wait, didn't you basically argue that you had to start her
to stop her from stalking you? Do you think that makes sense
to a lot of people that you had to like defensively
your stalker so that they would stop stalking you?
Do you Destiny, do you think that works? Do you think that makes
any sense to anybody else? >> for what's okay when they
do it. So, it's more useful to just, you know, unilaterally condemn
So, it's more useful to just unilaterally condemn like tactics
that >> Unilateral condemnation has never worked in all
of human history and nobody does it. That's why multiple people
on the planet have nuclear weapons and not just one party. >> Uh
so, just just real quick, Lav says that this is an example of
your community A-logging her. This is from the wiki, the Destiny.gg
wiki. Um and she sent me her page and where they give information
on her and this is the example that she has given of A-logging.
What is your response to this? >> I don't think one, I
don't think a wiki is like A-logging, number one. It could be
depending on the type of stuff in there if they're following
like day-by-day, okay? But two, the only reason why I have to
start having a wiki on my community is because people like Lav
will lie about so much. >> Like, okay, you understand that's
the entire like pretense of why there's a Kiwi Farms thread on
you, right Destiny?
Like quite literally, they would argue that you lie to get out
of every situation and so they have to record every single thing
about you because you lie pathologically
to get out of any trouble you could possibly be in. Like your
manifesto right now, I think you know that your manifesto is
like dead in the water because you had to lie pathologically
to your audience to justify being angry at people, to justify
going after people.
This argument you just gave justifies your entire Kiwi Farms
thread. Just just saying. Probably not the doxing part, which
is, you know, unlucky, unfortunate. I I totally just about that
part, but I'm just saying that obviously most of Kiwi Farms is
basically keeping track of content creators that they think are
like lying
Just saying. >> stuff. But the stuff that is on the wiki
related to Lav, it's stuff that's happened on my stream. Like
most of the stuff is still in YouTube videos or Discord links
to like like YouTube videos that exist right now. These are like
summaries and of arguments that we had. These are not like where
does she live now and where is she going to school? And where
are they trying to contact her? >> How long is it updated?
Or how often is it updated? >> I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know if there's a like way to track, I don't >> It's
a wiki so there's probably an edit history in it. >> Yeah,
is it would you say like it's probably A-logging if it gets contributed
to like maybe multiple times per week or >> I don't think
I'm sorry. What do you think A-logging is? Like what are you
saying here? >> her because >> Um, I think it was
like like refers to like covering like everything a perceived
like problematic or funny person is doing. >> With an obsessive
hatred behind it. There was the there was a guy who was I don't
remember the name, but Chris something or whatever who's A-logging
Chris Chan. I mean A-logging implies an obsessive hatred. >> I
okay, so I don't necessarily believe that it's always used to
denote the hatred portion, so sometimes people cover lolcows
that they're just they find like fascinating and want to but
they don't necessarily like >> Lav can't be like A-logged
really,
Cuz she like Sorry, at this point it's weird to even talk about
A-logging Lav because she just doesn't appear very much. She's
like not very online. She's like mostly in the real world. So
you can't you can't use Aiden's definition of A-logging. If you're
A-logging, it would be just all instances of her being online.
And she's not online that often. >> person like respectively
hate that person. There are some people that do, but I don't
think that's a necessary component for the A-logging. >> But
they're usually relying on other people that have A-logged them.
>> They're Okay, they're relying on other people which
means what?
>> As in they rely on other people that obsessively hate
these people and obsess over them to stalk them. They go they
go and they look at all the information they've posted about
them and then they cover it in a YouTube video. So if you're
So like the commentary community did this it's for a long time.
Hold on. I'm not saying the commentary community engages in A-logging.
But like when people are going to make YouTube videos on lolcows,
nobody talks about it in the commentary community. But oftentimes
what they would do is they would go to Kiwi Farms, they would
kind of summarize the information and then they make a YouTube
video about it cuz a lot of people on the mainstream internet
didn't know about, you know, Kiwi Farms. And that's what they
would do. I wouldn't say that the YouTubers were A-logging people,
but they relied on A-loggers who were usually like obsessed like
the people that are on Kiwi Farms posting every day about a person
or posting like really frequent life updates. These are like
obsessive people. >> I'll even close my eyes. One of the
claims that was being made about you was that you had been actively
engaging in communication with Anna after describing her as a
stalker. Is that true? >> Yeah, we so the we tried blocking
her for I think I don't even know how many months. We tried blocking
her for months. That wouldn't work. I tried being friends with
her again and then that seemed to work for a little bit and then
eventually something would happen and then she would lose her
mind for a month or two again. Then we would try being friends
for a little bit again. In those times she would also sometimes
try to sexually engage with me and when I say sexually I mean
like sex messages on online. But yeah, never stopped more than
one time. And then something would happen and then she would
like split again or whatever the [__] else we'd fight
and that this whole process happened over the course of I don't
know, maybe one or two years. >> Yes, but why if you if
you believe she's like some obsessive stalker, why why feed into
it at all? Why not just block her and never talk to >> It
doesn't matter if I'm talking to her, dude. You're not listening
to me. She is streaming every single day finding any comment
she can on the internet to She got partnered on Twitch because
you would cover me so much and she was getting viewer from other
communities that would go and watch it. >> Well then she
never >> The only thing I was doing was >> What other
communities were watching it? Bro, he's he's quite literally
just lying, right?
He's just There were other communities watching it. Anybody who
was in DGG around this time
knows that he's just totally lying. She had like 60 to 80 viewers
and literally 95% of them were DGGers the whole time. He's just
lying.
Like obviously, Aiden doesn't know this >> about me. Didn't
she eventually Okay, but do you not feel Okay, didn't she eventually
burn out and stop though? And do you not feel like engaging in
active communication with her will just reignite you in her head
and cause it to >> It did It didn't matter because one
that I don't know what finally stopped her. I think she finally
got medicated after like her massive Zherka burnout. But not
nothing that I Whether I was engaging or not engaging with somebody
It's not like I can see her not talking about her for 4 months
and they're still having daily crash outs about me. And it's
like I'm just I guess I'll just wait a couple more months. >> I'm
hearing that this gets even more slanted in Aiden's favor as
this goes on that Aiden just keeps winning again and again and
again. >> She's She's obviously passionate about it. Start
us sounded like she was like on the verge of tears as she was
discussing this. She was obviously very passionate. We let her
go on an entire >> Start us is my friend. Start us has
had my back. Start us has done things for me. Start us gets privileges
that Lav, who is not my friend, uh who I have no connection to,
does not. I give privileges to my friends. >> So Okay,
so you're on the sweeping of bias. Got it. Do you think that
Do you >> that by letting Start us speak more because she
is my friend, that I'm >> I think Yes, I think if your
claim is that you are supposedly the reason she's not Lav is
not in here is because you take pride with like the monologuing
and just a card. >> I don't have to bring someone on who's
>> I don't think you have to I'm not I'm just saying the
reason you provided the reason you >> You didn't say she
because you found her annoying. You said it was because she was
monologuing or that she wouldn't listen or that she would just
talk over But that's not what it is cuz Start us was doing that
and you didn't have any problem with it. Annoying you? Yeah,
sure. >> And if I think it's inconsistent
>> Annoying you by winning. >> No, I'm just I'm just
making a >> I'm not making a descriptive claim. I'm not
saying you need to be arrested over it. You're just obviously
being inconsistent. Okay, uh continue on you guys' debate and
stuff. I just needed to say that. So, yeah. >> My community
is not A-logging Anna. There's no A-log I don't know if there's
anything to A-log. She just don't lie on her stream every day
crying and screaming about >> Well, if they're monitoring
her streams every like when she's going live >> Today,
what person in my community >> It was one It was one person
in your community that was talking about her when she went live.
>> No, my my community was banned from talking about her.
They weren't allowed to mention her going live. >> it.
Well, yeah, it seems like you did that in response to A-logging.
That's why I'm not saying that you were >> Every Hold on.
Every single mention of another stream Come on. Wait, I'm I'm
going to lose my mind. Why are you doing >> like that's
the logic you guys are applying with Start us and Lav. So, I'm
>> Queen, if I were to go and look at film that thing called
and try to figure out how many times Queen has mentioned Stardust.
How many times do you think she's come up in in his YouTube channel?
>> Uh probably like in all the streams I don't know like
[__] 100 or something I already talked about like
if we're talking about all the camera rolls that's not that much.
I've been online for years like I've had like if you're if you
>> So over like four or five years, right? >> someone
like 20 or whatever he was making fun of or whatever. Um and
they're just like a personal like low caliber or whatever. It
wouldn't be that would actually not be like a huge >> Alav
is leaking my DMs in Jstark server. >> Yeah, that's of
course it is she always does and so >> Tell me my community
responding to
>> Wait wait wait wait wait. Is it is it this right here?
What is this? So Destor's floundering you're so dishonest it's
now it's insane. You'll have full time all the time you like
either A later or B another day. Stardust was on and silent for
the most of it or most of it and talked at the last bit before
going to see her bird. I'll let the audience judge between us
but you are just wrong. He even just lied about abortion to his
audience like a day ago. Like what the [__] You're
letting him get away with this. I was completely silent for five
minutes while everyone talked and then you let me talk and I
kept getting interrupted. Like are you joking? You're mad because
I said let me finish. Ridiculous. You kept getting interrupted
because we wanted to give it we wanted to take it one point at
a time. If you want to litigate this with me you can. I'm officially
inviting you. Come on Monday. I will give you a mic and a platform
and you can address any issue you have with me or Destiny. I
feel this is fair but you don't have to. You don't have to do
or you don't have to but I do and that's what matters to me.
You don't have to but I do and that's you don't have to but I
do. What does he have to do? Huh? Like holy quick you used to
be honest. Destiny talks about talks about these those people
all the time. If his justification is they're talking about me
then he should stop talking about them. You booting me off is
very cringe. I have solved I have solved points and then there's
a Pixie thing. What makes this different from A logging? Add
me back. You don't care about what he's saying or that he's saying
things unchecked actual insane
I have I'm not having you on because you weren't listening to
my moderation, you just kept going. I am sharing that you what
you are giving me, but when I share it and try and try to address
you, I'm also dealing with A other DMs and B streams. If you
have an issue with me, fine. Come yell at me if you want, but
I do not agree with your perception here. It is wrong. You are
incorrect, but at the end of the day, think what you will. Dude,
I didn't even get a warning. Status was on for 20 minutes. You're
not letting me on because Destiny was floundering. You're so
dishonest now, it's insane.
If you go one point at a time, Destiny will gish gallop and move
the goal post like he is right now. See, I can't fully pay attention
to what's happening right now because I'm having to deal with
you here. This is so I had literally 5 minutes of things to say.
I don't have a whole thing. It's not like It's not like long-form
content. You just didn't let me make the point. Hate me if you
want. That's the invite. I got to go try and deal with this show
right now. Yeah, I'm not doing that. Good luck with the weird
sweeping. Hope you find peace. Wow. Okay, well. >> So,
I I find I go live and I start screaming about Jidion and Jidion
like for instance, Jidion has been going live over the past I
think 2 weeks or whatever talking about me. I don't He's not
A-logging. me there. He's responding to the things that I'm saying
about him. You agree with that, right? Jidion is not A-logging
me over the past >> Sure, but even when he's covering [__]
that you're involved with with like other people and it's not
a direct response, I still say that's A-logging, right? Um I
don't view A-logging as >> No, nobody uses it that way.
You're I think people use it that way. It's not
Then what's his pro He He's literally complained about me stalking
him
This guy is like totally falling apart. I If If you're not basically
using A-logging and stalking as near synonyms,
right? A-logging is just stalking where you write stuff down,
I guess. I I don't even know like how How do we even remain
>> You're You're using a definition that nobody else in
the community uses. You don't think the term A-logging is applied
to like the repeated >> Use of his language is so tortured.
It's
It's tortured all the time, yes, and the the the speech is pressured.
Like you can hear that he is like about to explode all of the
time. He is like
He's like totally manic, basically. Wall-to-wall manic. Just
pure mania. >> distance and often frequent coverage of
a single individual that you have that you would take issue with?
No, actually I'm not No. >> A-logging is when you're are
covering somebody, generally with a hateful turn. It's not responding
to somebody though. When Justin was going live or you know every
day or whatever the [__] two weeks like covering
me, he's responding to me attacking him. He's not A-logging.
>> Has the bulk of his has the bulk of his negative coverage
about you just been responding to what you say about him? >> No,
of course. >> Yeah, of course. Yeah, that'd be great and
that'd be A-logging, right? >> No, no. I I don't know.
I would not know. Generally other people A-log for him, but that's
a different that's a totally different I'm just saying that if
I'm going
>> Are we serious? So, I'm not even the A-logger now. I'm
just Uh I see. This is how he's Okay.
I see.
I'm almost positive he said this about me multiple times, but
okay. >> People in my stream or people around me sometimes
would notice that Anna is going live and screaming about me because
she would reach out to me. She would reach out to other content
creators. She would sometimes go to other chats and start typing
and spamming. That's not other people A-logging her. She's like
A-logging herself. I I just don't know what the if a few people
in my chat which wasn't even happening, but were watching Anna's
stream when she went live to cry and scream about me that that
means that my community was A-logging Anna. That's >> Yeah,
I think if you're following like every people like she was a
nobody, right? Besides her association with you, right? I think
like obviously like people in your community would be naturally
interested, but like if but like if they're covering like every
like 20 viewer live stream, right? >> So, yeah, it's persistent,
frequent, repeated coverage. It's A-logging. >> I mean,
he wasn't doing this though. The only time people knew is if
she would try to get other people to notice. >> So, why
did you per your own admission like tell them to go to Kiwi Farms
>> This was months and months after because then there
people started posting on it and then instead of covering her
streams, people in my chat would say something like, "Oh, hey,
do you see this thing about blah blah blah blah blah?" And then
I because so many people keep bringing it up without mentioning
her name, we had a 1-minute moratorium or anti-moratorium on
Anna posting and I said if you want to talk about Anna, go to
the [__] Reddit and do it. Don't do it in my community.
We're not going to have people spinning [__] about
my community. >> Yeah, so so your so your community Yes,
so your community was A-logging and then you took corrective
measures. How is that not >> How is that not A-logging?
How is that not You have no response. >> You have NO RESPONSE.
>> YEAH, JUST LIKE THE REST. NO SUBSTANCE.
>> What do you mean no substance? What do you think I would
feel like if Justin and all these other people if Justin and
all these other people were to say, "Guys, we're not going to
talk about this anymore. If you want to talk about it go to Kiwi
Farms." What do you think I would say? >> Um you Sorry,
say that one more time. >> If Justin and all these other
Justin and Queenman Well, the substance guy, all these other
people, if they were to say, "Guys, we're not going to talk about
this anymore. If you want to talk about it go to Kiwi Farms."
What do you think I would say? >> You wouldn't You probably
wouldn't care about any of these people, sure. But I'm >> I
guess. I would say "Amen." >> But I don't
>> Yes, but >> But you already have a Kiwi Farms
thread, so it's not even remotely comparable. You literally already
have the Kiwi Farms thread. What are we talking about?
It's not even a comparable situation.
To to Anna's like new and and fledgling Kiwi Farms thread? Sending
people there? Versus what you have? >> It's not the same
thing. It's not the same thing. The dispute No, okay, there's
never going to be a one-to-one just because two things aren't
>> not even of the same kind of thing. That merely I'm
not maliciously linking Anna's Kiwi Farms thread, right? Okay.
>> This is the Aiden just real quick not to double team
me here, but I am going to hold on. This is why people are are
like I don't know if you're being honest here. It it's very hard
to believe that This is the This is the just you know, this is
the narrative. >> This is the thing that This is the thing
I always talk about. This is the thing. This is what they always
do. This is what they always do. Like you don't understand. This
is what they always do. I Okay. Like I Why Why not just point
out where he's
This is what they always do. This is like the the turbo Gish
gallop that I that I warn people about all the time. And then
he describes something that he's never described before. >> a
talking point that the soccer people desperately have to hold
on to because the Anna story is the most important thing that
Mr. Girl You know, he might actually be Mr. Girl. I don't know.
But this is like the one thing that they have to hold on. This
is the one thing they have to hold on to as hard as anything
because if the Anna story falls apart, every all of Lavin and
Mr. Girl's obsessive justification completely falls apart and
that's basically all they have for my history of crazy abusive
when it comes to other women. So the Anna thing is like that
he can never give on this. I have to the thread in a malicious
manner. My community has to have been A-logging Anna. I have
to have been telling my community she was crazy and sexy at the
same time. All these things have None of these things he can
give on. It doesn't matter how much I say or how many facts are
presented or >> Definitely Definitely not A-logging. Hold
on. Hold on. Uh drama timestamps from today from Destiny's stream
and deleted looping VODs. Destiny VOD one, talk one was continuous.
Talk two was more sporadic with bursts by Zerkaa and Dan. Anna
talk number one, 2 hours 54 minutes to 38 to 38 seconds to 4
hours 43 minutes 30 seconds featuring Mr. Girl. 3 hours and 35
minutes. YouTube thing with a with DGG for links. So this would
be would be the Vinier VOD, okay. Anna talk number two, 5 hours
27 minutes 57 seconds to 7 hours 25 minutes 10 seconds featuring
Zerkha, Jade, Dan, Lycan, Wicked Supreme, Sansoul. Deleted VODs
after stream. Twitch tracker viewership spikes is a good heuristic
to determine looping periods. The play is
Uh yeah, no, this is not a log in. This is not anything crazy
at all. This is like totally fine. This is like not even weird,
man. This is like not even weird even a little bit. This is like
not This is totally fine and normal and cool. And here's Viner,
who I don't even hate Viner, by the way. But Viner is a Destiny
employee right now. I'm just I'm just pointing it out. I I don't
think Viner's a bad guy. Viner's like a developer who's very
smart, very I think he's a little might but whatever. Okay? But
like
The guy who's at the top of the thread saying, "Thank you for
always keeping up the with the drama memes." is now a Destiny
employee.
I'm I'm
What are we supposed to say about that?
>> Do you think I like Do you think I like that they have
these talking points against you? Do you think I like that? >> You
think you can hear I was I was a huge fan of yours, okay? It's
disappointing. It's like disappointing I don't like
You're saying you're trying to You're trying to argue that I'm
suddenly predisposed biased against you when if anything I'm
actually upset like that they have something here, right? >> That's
how anti-fanning works. When you become an anti-fan, you don't
have a predisposed That was maybe 4 years ago, 5 years ago? >> I
was a fan of you since you were 12
>> I I I I would have been up until the Pixie show that
was like during COVID. >> It was the Pixie show that was
the one. >> So that was 5 years ago? You're saying you
had a predisposition to like the things I'm saying because you
were a fan of mine 5 or 6 years ago? >> No, I was a fan
of yours up until the Pixie dropped. >> When I was informed
of these arguments, they seem to be sound >> and valid,
so I've accepted them. What you presented to me to refute them
doesn't make any sense, right? That's what I've been >> What
doesn't make sense? >> Sure. Come on. Quick, play this.
Play this one. Here, 2 minutes. >> Okay. Give it to me.
Hold on. >> But no, you didn't though. >> randomly
come back and be like, "Oh, like new laugh during this Oh, this
happened blah blah blah." Listen, this is all I want. I want
to be in a world where neither of us ever mentions either person
ever again publicly ever. We don't have to talk privately. We
don't have to say anything publicly and then just move on. I've
had the same conversation with you like five times. >> They
continue to find It's not even me in my video. you try >> this
exchange? >> I think I think by the time after this
>> Did he How did he How did he know? How did he know the
perfect the perfect question to ask? Wait, did you say after
this or >> we did anymore. I think I I think after this
she had like one big final huge crash I think on this thing.
But even if I did, it wouldn't even matter. It doesn't matter.
SHE I IT
>> SHE HAD LIKE ONE big final huge crash I think on this
thing. But even if I
>> When you're definitely winning, when you're definitely
winning. This is the definitely winning face right here. This
is the definitely winning moment. We're definitely winning. We're
totally winning, guys. >> EVEN IF I DID, THOUGH. BUT EVEN
IF I DID, THOUGH. That's That wouldn't mean
>> Wait, why wouldn't it mean anything? Isn't your whole
Why wouldn't it mean anything?
>> It wouldn't even matter. It doesn't matter. I >> It
would matter for your claims. It would matter for I'm not It
would matter for your claims. You're making the claims against
her, right? >> matter for the claims SHE'S TALKING
>> YEAH, SO I GOT TO WANT TO DO A START would probably
be to not actively, you know, her, right? >> I She's the
one PURSUING ME. SHE'S TRYING TO ADD ME. SHE'S trying to add
my girlfriend. She's trying to add other people. SHE'S HOPPING
UP PEOPLE. I don't think we did after this one or whatever. But
like every strategy that I have ignoring her didn't work. Being
friends with her kind of worked a little bit
>> Is he going to do Is he going to do the defensive thing?
Guys, guys, I had I literally had to. I literally had to send
>> sent me sexual memes. We were sexual a little bit and
then whatever. But then eventually we go back and then we're
friends and >> I wish Aiden would just say like, "Hey,
could you like
would you maybe like slow down a little bit and just talk at
a normal speed so we could have a conversation? Like do you see
that you're kind of like pressured right now? You're manic seeming.
You're sort of like spilling all of this stuff out in a way that
nobody could ever respond to? Like you're you're sort of crashing
out really badly and spamming all these points out hoping I won't
respond. But if you just slowed it down like a little bit, we
could have a real conversation about this. But it seems like
you don't really want to have a real conversation at all. >> Trying
to add other people she's hopping up and down something. I don't
think we did after this whatever, but like every
strategy that I've ignoring her didn't work. Being friends with
her kind of worked a little bit. When she tried to be me we were
totally like that and whatever, but then eventually we go back
and then we're friends and then we go >> Kind of worked
a little bit.
When she tried to be
me we were
a little bit like that and whatever.
But then eventually we go back and then we're friends and then
we go back and then we're friends and we go back.
This happened for like two
>> Like I honestly I don't even need to like respond to
this in any way.
Like this is just the guy. This is the person at this point.
And I'm sorry. Like I I understand
I understand that I'm not doing something special here. I understand
that I shouldn't have to do this, but apparently I'm the only
person who thinks to slow this down and just listen to what this
guy is actually saying and how absurd he sounds. How awful like
how
low he sounds as a person. He just sounds like a like a loser.
Like he just the he doesn't talk in any way that makes sense.
He just sounds like a
Like I don't it's quite literally the cult is somehow elevating
this person who is like this into seeming normal, right? I I
I don't even know what Aiden says to respond to this to be honest
with you, but whatever. >> So somebody's like an obsessive
If somebody's like obsessed with you, don't you think like sex
can continuously lead them on?
It's not it's her fault. Do you acknowledge that that it's her
fault?
>> It's actually It's actually Aiden's fault. Aiden's the
one here. How did Aiden not understand what Destiny just said?
He was perfectly clear.
>> I did like I'll go to sex with her.
>> Then it's 100%. >> Well, it's not like >> Is
Aiden How did he not understand what was being said there? Aiden's
a [__] okay?
Aiden, stupid Aiden. >> I'm like a kid. It's not like it's
one person's fault like or I'm saying both >> Who Who Who
Who Who's the one that is driving No, no. Who's driving the interactions
on every single engagement? Who's the one that's pushing it every
single time? >> She's the one talking about you because
she's a But >> And who's hosting panels to have things
about it that that make content and memes about it? It wasn't
me, right? >> Yeah, but you're calling into those panels
and then you were after describing her as an obsessive stalker
>> And then calling her in calling into the Yeah, but describing
me as abusive and evil or whatever after trying to get into my
relationship. What What So what? >> Do you not think stalking
if you if that's what happened, you don't think stalking is more
likely to persist when you active when you sex the person you
believe and describe as >> Why is he yelling?
I don't know. I mean, he's agitated. He's a He's angry. He's
upset.
>> Stalking you?
>> Sometimes he's doing it Sometimes you do it for memes,
but like wouldn't you still want to deliver your points clearly
if you're doing it for memes? >> Okay, so I There's nothing
wrong with anything I've ever done to any girl as long as they've
also had sex with me then, right? >> There's nothing I've
ever done wrong with any girl so long as they've also had sex
with me then, am I right?
I don't think so. >> wrong you've done >> Me Me Whether
or not I've ever Whether or not I engaged at all sexually has
nothing to do with this. >> Yes, it does. >> Nothing
that I
that would justify HER IMPULSIVELY GOING LIVE AND TALKING ABOUT
ME EVERY SINGLE DAY. >> Aiden Aiden's calm handling of
this is so perfect right now. It's like the perfect offset to
what's going on with Destiny. It's very very very funny. >> Just
a housekeeping thing cuz I'm not I'm I'm actually not sure. Um
CounterPoints wants to ask you a >> No. No. No. You can
go diddle his own again. [__] that guy. No, I'm good.
>> Okay, fair enough. Wait, what?
What was that claim? Is that a new claim you guys have come up
with?
>> Nothing justifies Anna
talking about me obsessively for years. Nothing does.
>> That Aiden goes, wait, are you like claiming that? >> And
and Destiny just like goes
>> NOTHING JUSTIFIES WHAT ANNA did to me. Talking about
me obsessively for years. Nothing does. >> So I can probably
agree if I just look at this nobody's like claiming >> You
can't even agree with that? You think there might be a justification
for talking about me for years? >> Okay, but if you acknowledge
this person had a mental illness that predisposed them to obsession,
I don't know why feeding into that obsession by actively >> I'm
not talking about that. I'm saying that nothing >> I'm
just wanting to hear your claim that she was stalking you. >> about
No, no, no. My claim is nothing Okay, we'll drop stalking since
you don't want to own any strong claim against Anna. >> Well,
no, did she stalk you or not? >> You never will. You never
will. She did. Most people would agree with that, but you'll
never own a strong claim >> Stalking is not People are
not People they describe as stalking them. STALKING IS PERSISTENT
UNWANTED
>> WHAT? AIDEN DOESN'T KNOW anything about this and he's
he's winning because he doesn't know anything about it. That
Destiny like tries to throw little things in to upset Aiden,
but Aiden's like not invested. He doesn't care about it. And
so Aiden is just laughing at Aiden is just continuously being
like No, I don't I don't under Why would you say somebody is
stalking you? Why would you do that? >> Especially against
men, really? >> People That wasn't the claim I just made.
That wasn't the claim I just made. >> No, hold on. Stop.
You you don't All right, you know that people have sex with people
that are like you? >> That's like that's like sucking dick
and has a butt plug in and dick eating for like every week and
then complaining that they're stalking them. >> Uh there
we go. All the personal attacks, yes. Get them all out of here.
>> YOU ALWAYS PLAY THE VICTIM. That's literally all you
know how to >> I'M NOT PLAYING THE VICTIM. I'M TALKING
ABOUT NOTHING justifies >> I only personal attack YOU BECAUSE
YOU WENT FOR personal attacks. >> justifies. Nothing justifies
Well, you're making claims. Nothing justifies Anna Anna and a
about me excessively, every single day.
Nothing does, right? >> Sure, but this but she's has she's
saying something >> matter. No, no. It's either it is justified
or it's not. I need to I need a binary or a percentage on that.
What what could possibly justify her going public and talking
about me every single day? What could justify that? >> Well,
she probably believed you had emotionally hurt her in some sense
and she would solve something by talking about you, but I believe
that that wouldn't be an adequate justification cuz I don't think
talking about you was going to resolve that if she was talking
about you every day. >> thing, so then nothing justifies
her going live and talking about me, messaging my wife, messaging
other content creators, going into other streams and talking
about me. Nobody talks about >> from somebody that you've
already admitted has A MENTAL ILLNESS. >> IRRATIONAL. You
can't HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> YOU CAN'T CLAIM THAT SHE HAS OCD and to understand that.
And then when And then when Aiden goes, "I think the behavior
was because of her OCD." You go, "You're infantilizing her."
Quadriplegic can't go up the stairs, can't walk up the stairs
by himself, okay? Cuz he can't move. And you go to help this
guy, you go to carry him up the stairs AND JESS GOES, "STOP!
YOU'RE INFANTILIZING HIM. STOP TREATING HIM LIKE A BABY. LET
HIM GET UP HERE
NO? I ARE you out of your mind? >> You can't have it both
ways. You They're irrational and crazy They're crazy They're
crazy when you need to smear them, but then they have all the
agency in the world when it's time to defend >> Somebody
can have mental issues and still have agency. >> Yes, I
agree, but it seems like you were like using her obsessive nature
against uh you were using her obsessive nature against her and
then complaining that she was obsessive after you fed into this
relationship by >> Hold on. Okay, one more you play, I
guess like a minute from here or
>> Okay, give me a second.
This is going to show, guys. This is going to prove it. Go. >> Do
you know that you were you were psychologically abusive to me,
Steven. Don't deny it. Come on. Don't gaslight. I LITERALLY
>> BUT STEVEN, you literally ignored me. You gave me the
silent treatment. You did the stonewalling.
>> DMs is not abuse, Anna. >> Steven, that was after
you were ignoring me for literally months because I know you
were doing that out of anger and control. And my own therapist
said that. >> STOP. OKAY, STOP. WHAT THE [__]
am I supposed to do? I can't believe I let
hijack this narrative so much because you're so obsessed with
the
mister girl, and I know YOU ARE. YOU
>> DUDE, AIDEN
AIDEN HAS SAID NOTHING. Destiny just listened to this clip where
she's
where she calls him emotionally abusive. AND HE "STOP, STOP.
YOU'RE OBSESSED WITH THIS MISTER GIRL." It's like, "What?
The [__] are you talking about?
How is that even a response to anything
That's not a response to anything that's been said. It's not
a response to anything from the clip. It's literally not anything.
You have the arc You absolutely have the archetype for it, and
that leaked call from 6 months ago shows it, okay? 100% you have
the archetype of a mister girl. >> I don't like mister
girl. >> SAID SHE JUST SAID IN that call that I was ignoring
her for months. For months.
What the >> Well, first I'll have to see the context, but
do you not think that if the narrative is being perpetuated that
you used her obsessive nature against her, right? Apparently
you said And I'm I'm reading this one cuz someone said it in
my chat. I'll tell you exactly where I'm reading it from. Apparently
you said to her that you would like fix her reputation or something
while you're Yeah. It seems like you've been somebody that's
been willing to use that obsessive nature when it benefits you,
and obviously giving her just enough to keep the obsession going,
and then withholding affection absolutely can keep it going.
So, you just don't feed into it, right? You've been somebody
>> Destiny Destiny's been watching the hot
Hold on, Destiny's been watching the hot streams. And obviously
giving her just enough to keep the obsession going, and then
withholding affection absolutely can keep it going. So, you just
don't feed into it, right?
you just don't text her at all. You disengage completely. >> the
fixing her reputation
is when she would one of the things that she would loop about
and there are DMs from her mod coming into my chat talking about
oh god watch out guys she's looping again don't talk about her.
The fixing her reputation was me trying to delete every bad thing
about her on the internet. That was me fixing her reputation.
So me asking Abba to remove
No, it was
it wasn't removing stuff. It was saying she's not a stalker.
We actually do and we're like together or whatever. We're we
have like a relationship.
That's what she wanted.
I think it's even clear in the DMs what she wanted, right? The
the point is I'm not a creepy stalker. We have a relationship.
I'm not stalking you. We have a relationship.
I want you to say that we have a relationship. I don't want you
to say that I'm a stalker. I want you to say we have a relationship.
>> the video where he covered her massive crash out. Me
asking creators of the space please don't talk about it or ban
the thing in your chat if you see it. Me trying to go back to
my my Reddit
>> You going to those creators and getting stuff taken
down is a way to placate her without actually taking accountability
and saying no I do actually like this person and even though
I said they were stalker before that was me sort of being BPD
in my own and like crazy on my own and yeah it's my fault. It's
my fault.
Right? That's what you actually should have said. I overreacted
to her when I was upset and then it's been this like back and
forth but I am currently like trying to sex with her trying to
have a cordial relationship with her. So please don't call her
a stalker. I was
That would require taking some some kind of accountability though,
right?
>> to delete every bad thing about her on the internet.
That was me fixing her reputation. So me asking Abba to remove
the video where he covered her massive crash out. Me asking creators
of the space please don't talk about it or ban the thing >> This
never happened. I'm I'm >> You don't think that YOU'RE
NOT STOP STOP STOP DUDE. YOU CAN'T KEEP doing this. You don't
think You don't think You don't think You don't think what she's
she is constantly bringing me up even after ignoring her for
months. SHE'S MESSAGING EVERYBODY AROUND ME. You can TALK TO
OTHER CONTENT CREATORS SAYING THAT I'M ABUSING HER. When I do
ignore her, she's saying it's because I'm abusing her by ignoring
her. When I talk to her, she said >> Dude, when when Aiden
finally hits him with the could you just calm down a little bit?
When Aiden Aiden has to hit him at some point with the could
you just like calm the [__] down a little bit or
when Aiden does finally hit him with it's going to be catastrophic
for him. It's going to be cataclysmic. >> abusing her immediately
by talking to her. You can't keep doing this. Well, don't you
think that that that that that that that that that >> She's
driving this all of this. >> Okay, so it seems like this
person is obviously obviously has some like emotional disorder.
>> mentally ill. And don't you think it's the same thing?
This is it. You you guys are a broken record. No, I'm saying
you can't have it both ways. You can't have it both ways. You
can't have it both ways. Then when I invoke them, I'm supposed
to be trying to take away her agency. You're the one who says
you >> to address that please. He addressed that on that
stream that we just saw just real quick. On the stream that we
just saw, um
said that uh Destiny hadn't talked to her for months and she
considered that
>> And she was messaging people around me saying it was
abuse. And she was on these PANELS SAYING THAT I WAS AN ABUSER.
It's easy with like BPD people are easy to treat in real life.
You just ice them out. You don't talk about them. Online, they
start making
uh tweet longers about you or they start dating your ops secretly
and then they go on their stream for 6 months to talk [__]
about you. >> So so so so so so so the claim so the claim
gains traction that she's made then you just go on and address
that like dispute it. Um and if she has nothing, then it collapses
and you could just yeah. >> That's not how that's not how
it works. >> bro. He's >> Did hold on, I'm just curious.
Did you Did somebody uh did you suck a guy's 6 months ago? Did
this happen? Or did some guy suck you 6 months ago? >> Uh
yeah. Um yeah. I did >> Why the [__] did you
just say you don't get engaged in degenerate behavior then? >> What
did did I'm sorry, it's degenerate behavior uh to have guys suck
your
Did that really happen? I didn't cover any of that stuff. I didn't
care about that stuff. Did that really happen? >> Hey.
Aren't Isn't there literally a video of you on the internet sucking
a random guy's sack? >> Are you gay?
>> Why is Destiny Why did Destiny just say that? What the
>> Oh, bicurious?
>> I'm I'm not interested. I'm not
>> Because you called me degenerate as a insult earlier.
What the >> Okay, so I've only had sex with activity probably
with like enough people to name on one hand. >> You're
21 years old. No [__] >> Well, I don't care.
>> Okay, you're 20. Your 20s are sort of the time when
you're going around >> You're 21. YOU'RE NOT IN YOUR 20S.
YOU'RE 21.
>> WELL, YEAH. >> OKAY, please don't tell me. Okay,
I This is This is This is gone. It's true. That's fine. I'm sorry.
>> If anything, I I I'd I'd understand your [__]
I'd understand yours more if you were maybe like in your early
20s. I feel like that's like more of the appropriate time where
you're going around like a bunch of random people and maybe,
right? But like, you know, I feel like this would be the time
where if you where you would try [__] out and get
it out of the way. I don't know. >> I'm just saying, I
didn't have any guy guy experience when I was 21. That's all
I'm saying. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Enough. Enough. [laughter]
Enough. Enough. >> Only when you're 40. >> And the
videos are all up on the internet all over the world. So, yeah,
I >> Cuz I am I am I'm I'm done with this conversation.
I am done with this
That is the best move. That is the most sweeping move for Wick
right now, right? To end the conversation cuz
Destiny's like falling apart entirely.
It's crazy that this is all It has gone on in circles and we've
looped. You see This is what you do with Destiny. You just let
somebody else talk who he doesn't have any like He's always going
to try to reframe and attack, right? So, you just let somebody
else talk to him.
This is not ironically the strategy.
Right? Cuz all he's ever going to do is try to redirect to some
somebody else who's done something that he can point to and make
his audience not pay attention. If he has to argue against somebody
that he can't do that with, he loses. Like hardcore. He just
totally loses. It's over. >> Then looped and looped and
looped and looped and I think it's time to have some closing
thoughts. And let me ask ask you Aiden as a last thing and then
you can give your final thoughts on the matter and we can wrap
this up.
Earlier, right?
Couple weeks ago, you called on everyone to rally around to fight
against Destiny and DGG and things like that. Given what you
know now and the interactions you've had since, do you stand
by that call to action or have you become more neutral? That's
what I want to >> Whenever he says something that I believe
to be dishonest and then it's perpetuated and stuff. So whenever
he perpetuates
something that I believe to be dishonest and then a million like
random like sock accounts are perpetuating that narrative etc.
I say, you know what? If they respond with like five five of
those sock accounts reiterate his claims, have 10 that reiterate
the the claim that you can argue is truthful, right? So yes,
that call to action would remain if there's anything that is
said that I believe is a lie.
>> Okay, so currently that call to action is in force.
>> If he lies, if I believe he lies, yeah. >> Do
you believe he's lying? >> I think he's lied about certain
things, yeah. I don't think the whole I don't >> So it
is still in force? >> Yes, in response to the lies I get
sent me. Yes. >> Okay, final thoughts and then we'll get
Destiny's final thoughts and then we're then I'm done with all
of you for now,
>> All the all of this [__] is just me like
they're applying their own standards in these conversations.
They're applying their own standards in these dialogues and I'm
watching the inconsistencies happen in real time.